congressman paul gosar has been formally
and publicly condemned censured in the
parlance of congress for posting an
animated video depicting him
assassinating a democratic lawmaker and
attacking president biden for hours
yesterday democrats condemned him and
almost all republicans defended him when
the censure vote came the house divided
mostly along party lines this is the
first time any member of congress has
been censured in more than a decade it's
a rare undertaking nicole killian has
details from capitol hill
will representative gosar presented
himself arizona congressman paul gosar
stood in the well on the house floor
flanked by gop lawmakers as the censure
resolution was read against him
only two republicans joined democrats in
censuring gosar and stripping him up his
committee assignment after he posted an
animated video of himself flying in the
sky appearing to murder new york
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
and going after president biden with
swords
i do not espouse violence towards anyone
i never have
what is so hard
about saying that this is wrong
this is not about me
this is not about representative gosar
but this is about what we are willing to
accept
rules for thee but not for me
do you have no shame
but after a contentious vote gosar
received pats on the back and later
retweeted the video remaining defiant
the democrats have censored me for
challenging their america last agenda
they should know i won't be bullied even
they challenge me and try to take away
my
first agenda
gosar is in his sixth term in congress
and is no stranger to controversy he
voted to overturn the 2020 election
results and has spread false claims
about january 6. republicans say if they
take back the majority next year they
could go after democrats although
democrats argue this shouldn't be a
partisan issue gail
all right nicole thank you very much